what's the worst call you've ever seen  ever in any sport ever oh [ __ ] it's  an easy one the [ __ ] cardinals  getting [ __ ] over at first base  against kansas city  for a [ __ ] world series the cardinals  had it that poor umpire people took it  too far that guy had to change his name  he'd go whatever he got like death  threats what year was that bill 1985  and here's another thing too  everybody on the on the cardinals lost  their composure including their coat uh  manager whitey herzog  and it just carried into the next game  in game seven they lost like 14 to two  when the saints got that that what's it  called when the saints had that no call  i was like dude i've never seen a pass  interference where a guy literally  tackled a guy then the ball comes out  and it's like in those games dude it's  they need to figure something that would  have been bad enough if it was away from  the ball that was where the ball was  going